hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar resolving challenges in cell
media culture preparation i am sydney
mcneil of lab roots and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labruz and brought to you
by fujifilm irvine scientific
to learn more visit irvinesci.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and nuts
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits i'd like to now
welcome our speaker dr michael de la
cruz senior scientist at fujifilm irvine
scientific
dr michael de la cruz you may now begin
your presentation
thank you for the introduction good day
everyone thank you for joining
today we will be talking about how
fujifilm irvine scientifics
manufacturing science and technology
service can help resolve challenges in
cell culture media preparation
first i will provide an overview of the
company
i will then talk about the current
challenges in media preparation that we
have found across the industry
how we think our new msa offering may be
of service and how we'll be using
cutting edge technology to help you
minimize and improve efficiencies in
this unit operation
after my presentation i would like to
open it up for discussion i love to hear
the challenges you are facing in your
current process and any other questions
that i may answer
by the end of this webinar you will be
able to identify wrist and bottlenecks
in the drug sustenant manufacturing
strategies for streamlining by
processing workflows
learn the benefits of optimized media
design and engineering
and explore solutions for improved meta
preparation and simplify handling
methods
after you film event scientific our
mission is to develop and supply
products and services for the growth and
handling of amelian cells
wherever we can contribute to the health
and well-being of mankind
what some of you may not realize is that
for your event scientific is one of the
first media suppliers
we've been in the business of cell
culture media for over 50 years
and what distinguishes us is our
commitment to our customers success
we want to help you reduce the time
money and effort you are investing in
your process solutions
fujifilm urban scientific develops and
produces media for three markets
bio production cellulosin therapy and
assisted reproductive technologies
we are a trusted partner with very
strong quality systems designed around
medical devices requirements
and the principle that guides us is
customer satisfaction is not only our
goal it is our policy
we are expanding more than ever our
manufacturing capabilities now provide
global coverage
our headquarters research and
development team and our first
manufacturing facility are located in
southern california
our token facility has been operating
and providing service to our asian
markets for about 10 years
and provides business continuity for
commercial production
and we are very excited about our
expansion in europe where a new facility
is scheduled to open in december 2021
which will provide close connectivity to
our partners in europe
this new facility will increase
production capacity of 320 000 kilograms
per year for powders and 470 000 liters
per year for liquids
this proximity to our european customers
will greatly reduce lead times and
minimize disruptions in supply chain
first let's look at the current industry
challenges
the desire for better media preparation
methods was confirmed in a recently
published white paper which contained
some insights in this area of powder
media
a survey of 24 large-scale
biopharmaceutical manufacturers
was conducted and the highlights of the
data is shown in the bar graph
the top nine reported issues that were
ranked as having high importance
fall into two categories
increasing efficiency and reducing risk
for example
labor intensive power dissolution
time consuming bottlenecks could be
considered as efficiency related
problems
while environmental exposure
consistency and sterility could be
considered as risk related issues
this means that companies are spending
too much time cost and effort
and experiencing too many risk related
issues in media preparation
in addition the report included comments
on what specific problems concerning
large-scale powder media the respondents
would like to avoid
including
mixing and handling problems including
long mixing times and issues with
handling the powders packaging and
volatility
there's also issues with consistency
in which end users are accustomed to
seeing variation in our products
and attribute these inconsistencies to
the powders manufacturing process at
different scales
there's also comments regarding the lack
of industry information and support
the respondents commented the media
manufacturers don't have value and are
only concerned with filling orders never
suggesting or investing
investigating how things could be
improved
and lastly the respondents pointed at
the need for closed systems to minimize
exposure to the environment
this third-party information confirms
that there is a need for improved media
formulations and preparation methods at
the late stage of process development
as a media supplier we ask ourselves
how can the methods be improved
are these opportunities for innovation
with over 50 years of accumulated powder
media know-how we are ready to provide
the needed support and targeted
solutions to the late stage development
customer
we already understand that most issues
encounter fall within two major
categories
issues with media powder hydration which
can include
problems with solubility and
precipitation due to the speciation or
change in the oxidative state of media
components
an error due to human intervention which
could be due to overly complicated
preparation methods that include
unnecessary handling of raw materials
and avoidable adjustments to volume ph
and osmoladology
in response to these industry challenges
urban scientific is excited to offer our
new manufacturing science and technology
services
in early stage process development
fujifilm irvine scientific offers its
express media service which helps
customers quickly transfer from live
scale to manufacturing
this service provides solutions that are
suitable to our customers at the early
stages of process development
which are focused on speed to market by
supporting the pre and post ind
activities with the perspective of
entering the manufacturing facility as
quickly as possible
the express media service has a
well-documented creation of value from
innovation
but as companies move from early stage
to late stage process development we
recognize that their needs shift from
speed to reliability and costs
msat is focused on supporting late stage
process development by improving
meta preparation methods to result in a
more reliable and cost-effective process
the development of reliable and
efficient bioprocess workflows is
accomplished through close collaboration
with our customers where we work
together to identify opportunities for
reducing risk and costs the result of
this collaborative effort can include
improved powder solubility
simplifier preparation methods
troubleshooting of drug substance burial
materials
and application of automation and other
new technologies
msi service will help you manage risk
throughout the development cycle by
providing method validation and
performance qualification testing
this will ensure consistent product
quality and expected performance before
during and after preparation
by evaluating ranges of concentration of
components
and their effect on full powder
hydration
mitigating precipitation formation
during hydration
assessing short and long term stability
of both powder and liquid medium during
and after preparation
and ensuring that handling weighing and
hydration methods are both correct and
consistent and because we deliver a high
quality and reliable product designed
around your specific needs
the associated risk reduction will
benefit your manufacturing process
through an increase in efficiency that
translates to reduced costs
customers will not need to have entire
teams of individuals investing time and
effort in process solutions we can
easily reduce the time and effort that
you are investing in your process
solutions
for your film aeroscientific has the
capabilities resources and know-how to
help our customers improve their media
preparation methods
potential solutions include simplifying
and improving preparation methods by
targeting the final ph and osmolarity in
the final powder formula without the
need for final volume adjustments
or using equivalent metacomponent
substitutes with higher solubility
properties such as the sodium salts of
amino acids dipeptides or phosphorylated
forms of amino acids with improved
solubility
using alternate metacomplexes to avoid
precipitation due to oxidation or
optimizing the order of addition during
the preparation methods
to avoid precipitate formation
therefore for your film error scientific
is ready and capable of meeting all of
our customers needs including at the
late stage of process development by
improving your media preparation methods
depicted in this flow diagram is a case
study that provides a good example of
what the msat offering looks like
starting at the left on step 1 where our
customer received a panel of our media
we verify performance to screen
the customer used a mixture doe to find
an optimal formula and order the powder
with the final formula
from our express media service
going to step two the customers soon
reported issues with solubility and
requested our support
we then employ medium designing
engineering activities
known to resolve these issues and
similar issues with media preparation
which for this case included
the use of alternate metal complexes to
avoid detrimental changes in the redox
state of the components in solution
the elimination of all manual
adjustments to the ph of similarity and
final volume of the solution to simplify
their preparation method
and the use of equivalent media
components substitutes that have higher
solubility including the use of sodium
salts of amino acids and the peptides
these steps allowed us to redesign a
complex and insoluble media formula to
one that is simple and readily soluble
and as step 4 shows we provided our
customer with user-friendly media a
concentrated supplement solution that
addresses the solubility issues
encounter and a simplified preparation
method without unnecessary adjustments
in our reductions approach it is
important that we fully understand the
physical and chemical properties of
every component in subculture media
tyrosine is a prime example of a
component which is known to cause issues
during media preparation because
it is an aromatic amino acid and
therefore relatively non-polar which
means it has low solubility in water and
through ph
tyrosine chemical structure is depicted
in section a
tyrosine's low solubility is partly due
to the low acid disassociation constant
or the phenol side chain group
it is the only one of the aromatic amino
acids within ionizable side chain and is
one of three amino acids containing a
hydroxyl group since tyrosine is both
tripodic and dibasic
it has three pka constants
2.2 9.2 and 10.5
starting at the green square at the left
on section a we can see that the first
proton is removed from the carboxylic
acid at the first pka
moving to the right two spots the second
proton from the ammonium group is
removed at pka of 9.2
and finally
all the way to the right we see that the
third protein
with a pka of 10.5
the phenolic
protein from the amino acid chain is
removed
the left graph in section b is a
relative fraction plot which illustrates
changes in the relative concentration of
each ionic specie
on the y-axis across the ph values on
the x-axis
where the lines cross on the plot is the
ph when the acid and conjugate base
concentrations are equal
the second graph in section b is the
saturation curve which corresponds with
a relative fraction plot
only the first equivalence point
shows a large
change in ph with the added titrant
yet at the ph value where the second
equivalence point should be reached
there are several species in solution
the process of these three species in
solution together at this point creates
a buffering effect around the second
equivalence point
that counteracts the titrant effect
making it harder for the protein to be
removed from the amino acid side chain
and thus more challenging for the
tyrosine to be dissolved
the observed
small changes in ph with respect to the
addition of chatrin is clearly shown in
the graph on the right in section b
by understanding the chemical and
physical properties
of our components we can start to
formulate different strategies on how to
solve the specific solubility problems
encountered by the customers such as
providing these components as separate
concentrated solutions
yet the reductionist approach alone is
incomplete since we are not typically
making single component solutions but
complex media solutions with sometimes
more than 50 components
this is why we are also employing a
holistic approach to solving the
encounter media preparation issues
it is well understood that the
interactions between the media
components can lead to contrasting
effects in the solubility
for example graph a shows a schematic of
a ternary system
which includes two amino acids and in
water
this tenari system is used to
investigate the solubilities limit of
one amino acid as a function of another
amino acid concentration
graph b shows a trinary system
investigating the impact of the
concentration of alanine
on the solubility of leucine
in this case we see that as ionic
concentration increases the solubility
of
leucine is negatively impacted gravity
summarizes the results for the eight
amino acids tested against an increasing
concentration of alanine
as the results show the effects on the
solubility limit can be either positive
or negative depending on the amino acid
this data describing the interactions
between all of the components and their
effects
on each other's solubility limits can be
used to build predictive models that can
aid in the signing of the optimal
formula and preparation methods
here's another example of the effect of
median components interacting with each
other
in this case the interaction is between
an amino acid and the salt
this data shows the solubility limit of
cysteine
tyrosine and leucine on the y-axis as a
function of the cell concentration on
the x-axis
the results show that the concentration
of sodium chloride has desperate effects
on the solubility limit of each of the
tested amino acids in the case of
cysteine we see an increase in
solubility we saw concentration
while in the case of tyrosine and
leucine the solubility decreases
with
increasing cell concentration
discerning and understanding the
complexity of this interaction between
the salt and amino acids allows us to
design a media that accounts for these
complex interactions and provides the
best and most innovative solution to our
customers
fujifilm aeroscientific also used a
holistic and reductionist approach when
we created our balanced city media
products which are designed to be easy
to use and scalable into the
manufacturing facility
msab will complement these offerings by
leveraging our current capabilities to
help end users achieve their goals to
increase efficiency by reducing costs
and saving time
as well as their goal to reduce risk by
improving supply continuity to achieve
lean and agile manufacturing
in order to meet your future needs we
will service connections regarding its
resources that complement our service
one of those resources is the advanced
by medium biomanufacturing innovation
center or ambik which is a consortium of
academic labs and industrial
collaborators
both fujifilm diocesan biotechnologies
and fujifilm iron scientific are current
members of this consortium
this gives us exclusive access to
technology knowledge design tools and
methods developed to fast-track advanced
biomanufacturing processes
ambig has developed several software
tools
to facilitate cho bio processes by
modeling and predicting media component
interactions as well as tools to predict
nutrient requirements and amino acid
concentration level changes
that are used for medium optimization
this image shows graphically one of the
algorithms used in the complication
modeling tool
it is the nutrient concentrated gui
developed to characterize the
thermodynamic environment of media
solutions we can see that it is quite
complex it integrates several databases
containing complexation and solubility
information accounting for the chemical
and
physical properties the multiple
possible species of each of the medium
components while in solution
and it employs
mathematical calculations to predict
their interactions and complex section
of these components in the aqua solution
as a function of ph here are some
examples of the type of results obtained
when using these ambig software tools
graph a and b are two examples of the
outputs
once again these are relative fraction
plots which illustrate the change in the
relative concentration of each ionic
species
on the y-axis across ph value
on the x-axis
where the line cross on the plot is the
ph when the acid and conjugate base
concentrations are equal
the broken lines identify the potential
sources of precipitation
while graph a is more complex solution
with more components and interactions
than graph b
both still show potential sources of
precipitation
as you can see these tools are helpful
in modeling potential sources of
rectification in a quick and cost
efficient manner
another type of data that's available
are these heat maps that can be built
from the ternary plots shown here on
graph a and b
it depicts the computational prediction
of the impact of one amino acid and the
solubility limit of all other protonomic
amino acids
the blue color represents a positive
impact on solubility while the black
color represents a negative impact on
the solubility
with a simple color difference blue or
black one can see with whether the
impact of one amino acid
on another will be either positive or
negative
on the solubility limit
it is clear that a huge challenge exists
when attempting to design a medium that
is
balanced to minimize the negative impact
on solvability
while still achieving the expected
performance
here i'm showing another type of data
obtained from one of the software tools
intended to optimize the meta
preparation method
after inputting meta components into the
tool it will group the media components
into pots
and suggest an order of addition of the
individual components during the
preparation method to avoid any issues
all of these
examples of insulin modeling provide
efficient and cost-effective ways to
address the encounter issues in meta
preparation
during the late stages of process
development
so in takeaway we have identified
customer gaps fujifilm everest
scientific has the resources
capabilities needed to address these
gaps
and with the rollout of our new msat
service offering
we will be able to meet customer needs
at the late stage of process development
thank you for listening i'd like to open
it up for questions or comments
thank you dr michael de la cruz for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for let's get started
our first question is
what basic strategy should i follow for
improving cell culture media preparation
and ensuring process robustness
yes um thank you for the question that's
definitely
something that we look for um
we're trying to achieve here yet um
when we're trying to
utilize the service um we're looking for
the many ways that we can improve
the solubility of components
given that there are
limits to what we can do but
you know
one thing that we'd like to
do for sure is eliminate any of the
adjustments that we typically do when
we are
compounding and solubilizing our media
we don't
you know our goal would be to have that
one powder
in
whatever
amount of water that you would need for
the total amount that you're
trying to um batch
and basically add it in boom it goes
into solution but we know that that's
not always possible because of the many
um interactions that i was
speaking of here in
in in in the solubility limits that are
um they're not achievable
so um
given that we like to um you know think
about the other ways that we can do um
so in
one of the best solutions that i've seen
is this ambig tool
where it allows you to sort of see the
order of addition that is
the best
um for your formulation
so you can specifically
input your um
your
specific formula
and this will allow you to see
if
you can
put your components within
what they call pods
and
for example i've
you know in the past i've been able to
actually um divide a
quite complex feed media a concentrated
thing media into
two powders
and be able to concentrate that in media
up to like you know multiple 100 like
almost 100 x over restarted
so
there are ways to avoid um certain
interactions and also
to meet certain um
you know ph for example um
maybe
you know as we divide these powders we
were also thinking about
ph so for example one powder was more of
an aesthetic ph so we would start with
that one and then we would add the
second powder which is a more basic ph
and that would allow us to come into
the neutral ph
at high concentrations
and
we were able to
resolve some of the issues that way
i mean there's also other ways that you
could um
improve solubility of components such as
using um bipeptides or the new
phosphorylated um
amino acids that are available
and those have um i see that they have
seen
pretty useful in in many cases
but um but yeah i mean any other
questions
yes thank you our next question is
what techniques can you suggest for
improving hydration of powdered cell
culture medium that is difficult to get
in solution
right i was just getting into that as
well
um
so we know of many of the
amino acids that do give us
or the components that do give us
most
problems so
like i said you know you could
definitely
improve solubility by
finding components that are more soluble
if you're able to reformulate that
formula
yet you know in many cases where we are
at the late stage that's
not possible you know there's
really a limit of how much change you
can do to the formula and their ways
where we will utilize these other types
of um
you know strategies where we can start
to divide the powders and
um i think that that's
less of a change since you're not
changing the formula the final formula i
think we believe that we will be able to
introduce that change into a late stage
process
but um yeah there's many other ways to
to increase solubility of potter media
and but we definitely like to
avoid
having any adjustments
so
the way that we um
we do that is by actually
[Music]
having the correct balance of the
the sodium
that is in within your or the yeah the
the
sorry the hydroxide that is in your
media so that as you're um just
introducing it to the liquid
you know you're basically end up in the
right ph concentration and i've worked
with recently with
a media that is is a is a production
media so it's a growth media so it's not
very concentrated but yet they were
having some solubility limits with
a tyrosine for example
so we did have to um
take that out of the formula and make it
into a
a
concentrated
high pa solution
and just by simply doing that
minor change we were able to
get that
problem resolved
so there are many many strategies that
one can follow to
resolve all these issues
great thank you our next question our
next question is in a dual ternary amino
acid solution
modification of ph is a way to improve
solubility or addition of in a product
solvent such as dmso one to five percent
right um
there's definitely many other um
components that actually will improve
solubility of
of your media um
yeah i mean that's definitely an
approach using the mso although that's
not always possible um
we know that
it could become um
you know some cell lines don't quite
like
the use of dmso
um depending on on
the product and the cell line that
you're using that definitely could
be something that could
help with solubility limits
but you know
there are many other even
something as simple as sugar
you know your amount of um
sugar may
have an impact on your solubility
or your stability actually
i think that
if my
if i were to
for example
take out
my the glucose from my
formula
i would see the precipitation
you know within 24 hours of that formula
where when the permanent had the glucose
in it
it was perfectly fine so it really
though all depends on
all these interactions and really
understanding
you know how um
yeah they're they're really
impacting how what kind of species are
being
formed as you're adding these components
and um that sort of gives you um
this more of a stable environment
so that um when you
have this liquid medius in storage they
um
the interactions among these components
will be reduced and
that way you could avoid precipitation
thank you our next question is
can you contrast the commonly
encountered stability issues for
powdered media compared to liquid media
yeah that's very interesting question
because i just recently um
had a project where we just see
a large impact of um
of
in the um
in the stability of the powder media
which is surprising because typically we
think of powders being very stable
and
we prefer to
have it that way so we could
um store it in
you know not have issues but we see that
um
certain powders especially
this one that was a very highly
concentrated
feed
and also contain many
hygroscopic
components we saw that the amount of
moisture had a huge impact on the
stability of that powder media
so although
we do prefer to
give you the powder because it's more
stable
you know
we do see that
even in powder we have to be really
careful
um about how we handle
these powders and how we store them and
how long can these powders be stored
so we're looking for
really
many solutions for these type of issues
um including you know packaging
and
other ways to minimize that
amount of moisture
in the um
in in the powder
so
yeah most people do prefer to start with
powder because it's more stable
than liquid because of the um
the interaction between the chemical
components is you know less when you're
in powder but yet nevertheless there is
interaction going on um
you know even in the powder form because
um there's a certain amount of moisture
there
so minimizing that is definitely key
that's something that we've seen
perfect thank you our next question is
do you have experience helping with cgt
manufacturing processes
yeah i mean we have a lot of um
a lot of expertise within our group
i personally haven't worked with cet
but i
my entire
organization
we have
like as i mentioned
other groups that are um within those
areas and there will be
i will be happily
able to um
to connect them with whom whoever would
like to
have any information that is you know
pertinent to them
so i was wondering what specifically
about
cgt manufacturing processes
was the
question about but
yeah we have expertise
within that area as well
perfect thank you our next question is
would recombinant proteins help with
stabilization
or i'm sorry stabilization and
consistency in liquid mediums
yeah i mean
as i mentioned
these
especially macromolecules will
definitely have a huge effect
on your stability definitely i could see
that
um
you know certain
um i'm not really sure which one you're
supposed to be referring to but i could
definitely see that being a
a way to improve
stability of your media yeah
perfect thank you our next question is
are these improvements tied somehow to
the use of your own proprietary media
formulas or could we also ask for help
with formulas that we ds producer own
yeah i mean this this is nothing um
i guess we're not nothing that it's not
really
available out there i mean anyone that
can
um
that has the knowledge um or is able to
do
the right you know searches can find all
this information you know we're not
doing anything
um out of um you know
that is
magical anything like that i mean this
is um simple chemistry that we're doing
here
and um
yeah i mean this is applicable to any
formula um
there's nothing really special about our
formulas you know tell your truth so
um
although we do like to brag that they're
they're better than
anyone else but that's
um that's beside point these these um
solutions that can be applicable to any
formula
out there so
um if you do need our help
um we're here
great thank you it looks like we have
time for one final question
can you clarify how we can gain access
to this service do you have to be a
current customer and are you charging
for this service
yeah um
so
you could definitely um contact us um
there are um several ways that you could
do that is just
simply um
you know
do an inquiry with our um
our main technical
services
but um
and they will definitely
put us in contact with you
as far as a fee um um
you know we are doing this
um really not as a um a way to to make
money but we really like to um
especially that that one comment
um about the media service or the media
companies not caring
just you know we just want to sell you
the media and
you know i as an as a user actually have
experienced that
and
i think
companies like fujifilm neuroscientific
realizing that
you know we really need to be
connected to
our customers and really understand what
their issues are and we like to take on
this um
this burden these issues and help you
with the um
with this particular inner operation
which i think a lot of people have
thought of as very um very simple and
and not critical but
um
more and more as these
processes are becoming complex
we're seeing that
the media
is becoming also complex and
therefore um
you know
the uh that complexity adds on to the
risk so we want to really help you
minimize service by
simplifying your methods
and um providing you a formula that is
going to be you know fairly soluble and
stable
and you will have to you you can't count
on that formula
perfect thank you
thank you again dr michael de la cruz
for your time today and for your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor fujifilm
irvine scientific for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye